(electronic clicking)
(calm music)
- So good afternoon.
My name is Vince Resh and I'm a professor
of the graduate school and the Department
of Environmental Science,
Policy & Management
at Berkeley and I feel like I've been
the lifelong chair of the
Hitchcock Memorial Lecture Series
and it's been one of the real joys
that I've had at being at Berkeley.
Our committee along with
the Graduate Council
is pleased to present Dr. Eugenie
Scott as this full speaker
in the Charles M. and Martha
Hitchcock Lecture Series.
Now as a condition of the request,
and we're happy to do this actually,
we wanna tell you a little about
how this endowment came to Berkeley,
and there's more information
in the brochure about this,
because it's really a
story that exemplifies
the many ways that the campus is linked
to the history of California
and especially to the Bay Area.
Dr. Charles Hitchcock was a physician
in the United States Army
that came to California
during the Gold Rush.
He opened a thriving
practice in San Francisco.
And in 1885 he established
a professorship at Berkeley
as an expression of his long
held interest in education.
His daughter was Lillie Hitchcock Coit
who's one of the fascinating characters,
and many of you have
probably been to Coit Tower
to see the beautiful murals
that her family was involved in.
And a very, very colorful personality.
She expanded her father's original gift
and made it possible for us to present
this series of lectures.
So over 100 years later, 130 years later,
the Hitchcock Fund has been one
of the most cherished endowments
on the Berkeley Campus
recognizing the highest
distinction of scholarly thought,
achievement, and accomplishment.
Thank you to the Lillie
and Charles Hitchcock,
and now let me open with a few words
about Dr. Eugenie Scott.
Dr. Scott is a renowned anthropologist
and science educator.
She became the Executive Director
for the National Center of
Science Education in 1986.
The center, as many of you know,
is a non-profit organization
based in Oakland
whose stated mission is
"to defend the integrity
"of science education against
ideological interference."
Dr. Scott headed the center for 30 years
before retiring in 2014.
Now our speaker received
her BS and MS degree
from the University of
Wisconsin, Milwaukee,
and her PhD in Biological Anthropology
from the University of Missouri.
She later joined the faculty
of the University of Kentucky
as a professor Physical Anthropology.
She's taught at the University of Colorado
and Cal State University, East Bay.
At the National Center
for Science Education,
Dr. Scott's work centered on attempts
to teach evolution as simply
one of a series of hypotheses
about human origins
such as ever teach creation science
and intelligent design in
American public schools.
In 2005 she and her
staff worked on the side
of the plaintiffs in the well-known
Kitzmiller v. Dover Area School District.
This was the first case
in the US federal courts
to directly challenge the teaching
of intelligent design in public schools
alongside with darwinian education
as an alternative scientific theory.
The US District Court for
Middle District of Pennsylvania
ruled in favor of the plaintiffs
that intelligent design
was indeed a form of creationism
and therefore its teaching violated
the establishment clause
of the First Amendment
of the US Constitution.
A prolific author, Dr. Scott's 2004 book
"Evolution versus
Creationism. An Introduction",
offers an overview of the ongoing
public dispute and concise history
of the controversy surrounding
evolution and creationism.
In addition to writing she is considered
among media and press coverage.
In 2010 the National Academy of Science
awarded Dr. Scott the Public Welfare Medal
for Extraordinary Use of
Science for the Public Good.
Now some of you may know this analogy
that's been applied to Dr. Scott.
If you remember back in Darwin's time
they referred to Huxley
as Darwin's bulldog.
They've also referred to
Dawkins, Richard Dawkins,
as Darwin's greyhound which is
Eugenie once said that's not
necessarily a compliment
if you know greyhounds.
But she has been described
in a beautiful, eloquent terms
as Darwin's golden retriever.
So in her lecture today Dr. Scott asks,
why do people reject good science?
Now, reasonable research has highlighted
the importance of ideology in shaping
what scientific inclusions are
that are considered
reliable and acceptable.
And of course this
research is quite relevant
to the evolution in climate change wars
and to other questions involving
the rejection of empirical
scientific evidence.
I've been a fan of Dr. Scott's for years
and it's really a pleasure,
so join me in welcoming her to Berkeley.
(crowd applauds)
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you for coming.
- Thank you, Vince.
(crowd applauds)
Thank you very much.
You know, actually greyhounds
are pretty cool dogs
when you come right down to it.
It's golden retrievers that are,
they're really nice dogs and everything,
but they're kind of dumb.
But they just wanna get
along with everybody.
So we'll see if you pick up
on any of that in this story.
Thank you very much, Vincent.
As Dr. Resh said I've spent
most of my professional life
at the National Center
for Science Education,
so I have been dealing a lot
with people who don't
agree with scientists
even on topics like evolution
which is foundational to
entire academic disciplines.
So for a long time I've been interested
in this question of why do
people reject good science.
Now there are a lot of things
that people get wrong, okay?
You know that Woody Allen joke about
I just finished the Evelyn
Woods reading dynamic scores.
In four hours I read War and Peace.
It's about Russia.
(crowd laughs)
People believe that eyewitness accounts
are really highly reliable,
and one of my favorites, we
only use 10% of our brain.
Like 90% our Brian is just sitting there.
I don't know what to do.
But there are a lot of things
that we're wrong about.
But stuff like this tends to be
changeable with more information.
If you explain to somebody why
I only use 5% or 10% of my
brain really isn't accurate,
most people will say,
oh, okay, that's fine.
But then there's a whole bunch of stuff
that people are wrong about
which seem not to be very susceptible
to changing with new information.
The 9/11 Truthers, the
creationist, climate deniers,
aficionados of the moon
landing being a hoax,
providing more accurate information
doesn't seem to change their opinions
or make them alter their erroneous views.
So there seem to be some erroneous ideas
that people change their
minds about and others that
about which they are
quite knowledge resistant.
Now we as individuals in a society
have to make decisions that
require accurate information.
Sometimes this information
comes from science.
If my baby gets a measles,
mumps, rubella vaccination,
will my child get autism?
Are GMO foods safe to eat, et cetera.
I'll mostly be talking about two fields
about which, in science,
about which I have most expertise
which is evolution and climate science.
But there are a lot of
things that people get wrong,
that people need scientific
and other factual information
to make good decisions.
So let me just set the stage
by taking a look at those two fields
of evolution and climate change
and how the public looks at them.
Now anti-evolutionism in the United States
has had a depressingly consistent past.
The top line is Gallup's question
about human beings were created
in their present form
about 10,000 years ago.
Traditionally about 40, mid
to high 40% of Americans
have answered yes to that question.
In the last couple of
years, interestingly enough,
it's been declining.
And in 2017 it was below
40% for the first time.
The middle line is Gallup's
question that humans evolved
but God guided this process.
A point of view in religious circles
known as theistic evolution,
and this question is usually
answered by about mid-30%,
35, 37% of Americans.
Increasing recently to the high 30s
which is kind of interesting because
the Young-Earth creationists
are sort of going down at the time
the theistic evolutionists are going up.
That's a correlation,
we don't know if there's
any causation in there.
The bottom line is Gallup's question
about humans evolved, but sorry.
Humans evolved but God was
not involved in this issue.
Now this question has
been answered by Americans
in roughly the low teens,
even eight, nine, 12, 13%.
It's been on a rise
during the last decade.
And interestingly enough in 2017
it was the highest that it's
ever been recorded, 19%.
In any regard whatever
the percentages are,
Americans have a much lower
incidence of acceptance of evolution
than people in literally any
other developed country in the world.
Climate change is a little better.
And the 2017 study published by
the Yale Program on Climate
Change Communication
showed, this is the black line there,
over half of registered voters
accept that global
warming is caused mostly
by human activities.
Now of course if you go to most of Europe
and most of Asia the percentages
are like 60, 70, 80%.
But the fact that we're
over half is progress
'cause this is the highest
it's been for a long time.
The blue lines show that Democrats,
both liberal Democrats and
moderate conservative ones,
had a higher acceptance
rate than Republicans,
and the red line show that Republicans
in general are less favorable
to accepting anthropogenic climate change.
When we compare attitudes
of the public to scientists,
we find quite a large gap
in several science issues.
I wanna use as my starting example
the top line of this chart,
is it safe to eat
genetically-modified foods?
88% of scientists say yes,
37% of the general public.
That's a 51 point gap
between the acceptance of this principle
from scientists versus that
of the general population.
There are 37 and 33% point gaps
between scientists and the public
on climate change and human
evolution respectively.
So how come?
Well, maybe knowledge
resistors are just stupid.
Maybe the 9/11 truthers and creationists
and those who reject anthropogenic
climate change are just dumb.
I suspect this is highly unlikely.
Nobody's out there giving IQ tests
to 9/11 truthers or anybody else.
But from what we have seen
and talking to these people,
my hypothesis would be, and I
think it could be corroborated
that there's the same range
of normal intelligence
amongst deniers of these scientific views
as well as anybody else.
I don't think stupidity
is really the answer.
Maybe they hate science.
Well, this is something that
we can actually look at.
So how many of you think
Americans are anti-science?
And I won't call on you
so it's safe to raise
your hand, it's okay.
See, a lot of you raised your hand.
Oh, she's not gonna call on me, it's okay.
So quite a few of you did raise your hand.
Well, let's take a look and
see what the data is saying.
Well, if Americans are anti-science,
they're keeping it a secret
because pretty much every
survey for the last 30 years
that I've seen, and believe me
I obsess about things like this,
shows that Americans are
very positive about science
in this recent Pew Research Center data.
The majority of Americans believe
science has a mostly positive
effect on society, 67%.
That's a really large number.
Only 4% of our fellow citizens
feel that science has a
mostly negative effect.
And there's other indicators as well.
A somewhat earlier Pew study
show that Americans
find science beneficial.
79% think science has made life easier.
And in terms of health care,
food supply and the environment,
very high percentages of Americans
also think that science
has had a positive effect.
If Americans were anti-science
they would not be likely
to trust scientist
to be reliable sources of
information on important issues.
The health risks of the MMR
virus, or sorry, vaccine.
We know the health risks of
the MMR, more viruses than one.
The causes of climate change,
the health risks, and
benefits of eating GMOs.
Notice that Americans are more likely
to go to scientists for information
on these questions that they might have
than two other people
who might have expertise
in this issue.
You might notice where
elected officials are.
Interestingly enough.
In this 2014 Harris Poll on
occupations and prestige,
scientists are right
up there with doctors,
firemen, and the military
as high prestige occupations.
And in what I think was a
most interesting question,
would you want your kid
to think about a career in these fields?
When people are asked this question,
scientists again are right up there
with doctors and engineers.
By the way politicians are
really low on this list.
And there's lots and lots of polls showing
these similarly positive
responses to science.
So how many of you think that
Americans are anti-science?
There are still some
knowledge-resistant people out here.
All right.
(laughs)
My hypothesis on this is that
Americans really like science.
I mean we're very positive about science.
All the survey research data shows that
grandma got a new hip,
she's bowling again.
We really, really like science.
But we just don't like that science.
We just don't like this science.
I think we pick and choose the sciences
that we don't like.
But in general science has got good press
which I think is very positive
for those of us who are
interested in science.
Denying climate change or evolution
is not the same as denying science.
Maybe people who reject
the scientific consensus
on issues are just ignorant.
Noting of course that
there is a difference
between stupidity and ignorance.
One is curable.
This would be very good to know because
if the reason why people
reject scientific views,
which are well founded in science
is because they don't
know enough about it.
If more information
could change their mind,
this would be a really good
solution to this problem.
If it's just ignorance,
if we provide them with more information,
they'll change their
opinions, this is great.
It is clear that this is the opinion
of about 89% of the people
who are on the internet.
It's a joke.
(laughs)
If you carry it says,
aren't you coming to bed?
I can't, this is important.
What?
Someone is wrong on the internet.
When I first started dealing
with the creationism and evolution issue,
I really thought that if I could only
explain the science
really, really clearly,
come up with gripping examples,
communicate my excitement and enthusiasm
of the science that
people would say, yeah,
okay, you can teach this stuff to my kid.
Didn't work out that way.
I learned fairly early
in my career at NCSE
that you can't just shovel more science
under this topic and expect it
to make any difference.
People who's wrong in the internet,
people will always come
up with reasons why
they cant' accept your information.
This is called the
knowledge deficit model.
And it has to do with the idea that
knowledge resistance if
the function of ignorance.
Cure the ignorance, the knowledge
resistance will go away.
Unfortunately reality is a
lot more complex than that.
Dan Kahan and his colleagues at Yale
surveyed a group of Americans.
They asked them about their
attitudes toward climate change
and they also collected information
on their general scientific knowledge
and mathematical ability.
And the hypothesis is that if ignorance
is the explanation for
knowledge resistance,
then we'd expect that
people who know more science
would be more likely to
agree with scientists.
And what they found was that
the more knowledgeable people
tended to be less concerned
with climate change
which is not what the knowledge deficit
model would predict.
And there's a lot of other
research in the same vein.
So what can explain knowledge resistance?
Well apparently it is
not stupidity, ignorance,
or hatred of science.
So what is it?
Well to summarize an
awful lot of literature
and the psychology of belief area,
there are a lot of concepts which overlap
quite a bit to cultural cognition,
motivated cognition,
confirmation bias, et cetera.
For my purposes today,
all of these concepts
refer in some way to
viewing factual information
through a filter.
And the filter is a values and ideology
or a group identification filter.
Some or all of the above.
We social primates share
values and ideology
with members of our group.
It's part of the way we identify
as members of a group.
It's part of the way that groups
inculturate the younger
members of the group,
values and ideology are
extremely important.
And some things about which we are wrong
we can change our mind
about fairly easily.
Things about which we are wrong
which impinge upon our
ideology, our values,
or our group identification
are very resistant to change
in the form of a variety
of these concepts.
And let me talk a little bit about that
'cause I find it a very
interesting problem.
Before I do though let me do something
that might seem rather odd.
I'm gonna put in a good
word for ideology, okay?
In the cartoon science is obviously
banning ideology from the laboratory.
Science is good, that means
ideology has to be bad.
And I don't think about ideology as bad.
When I talk about people having ideologies
or knowledge resistance
as a function of ideology.
I'm not dissing them because they are
expressing ideological views.
I look at ideology, the word ideology
the same way that I look at
the word operation, okay?
An appendectomy and a lobotomy
are both operations, okay?
I've had one.
(crowd laughs)
I think I'll just let that float,
let you draw your own conclusions.
But everything is context.
There's a difference in context between
an appendectomy and a lobotomy, obviously,
but they're both operations, right?
Similarly with ideologies,
there are ideologies that are
destructive and injurious.
There are ideologies that are
beneficial and fulfilling.
Ideologies affect how we shape our lives,
and every single person in this room
is a whole matrix or bundle of ideologies.
One can be a feminist,
humanist, environmentalist.
I know somebody like that.
Feminism, humanism, and
environmentalism are isms,
they are ideologies.
If you embrace the ideology of feminism
then you hold certain views
about the relationships
of males and females,
the equality of males and females
in different areas, et cetera, et cetera.
Ideologies shape how we run our lives,
and they are extremely important.
And they are not necessarily negative.
Context is everything.
But again we social
primates live in groups
and our ideologies help
make us part of a group, our values.
It's a very human thing
to have ideologies.
Now where problems arise is where
an ideological position prevents us
from looking dispassionately if you will
at empirical evidence, facts, and logic.
It's a very difficult thing
for we human beings to do
to set aside our values and our ideology
to look carefully at evidence that may
cause problems for those
ideologies and values.
It's a very human thing,
it's a very difficult thing.
Nobody does it all the time
and hardly anybody does it really well.
So let's take a look
at ideologies, values,
and identifications and how they
can affect knowledge resistance.
Working with some ideas
from the anthropologist
Mary Douglas, Dan Kahan and his colleagues
suggested that people can be placed along
two axes depending on their values.
There's an individualist
communitarian axis,
and a cross cutting
hierarchist egalitarian axis.
Now everybody has tendencies
on one or the other
and you can go to the internet
and you can find a quiz that'll put you
in one of these quadrants.
And so everybody has
some tendencies of these
but people would be placed differently.
Republicans are more likely
to be hierarchical and individualistic.
Democrats are more likely to be
egalitarian and communitarian.
Libetarians are
egalitarian individualists,
and I didn't know that their
symbol was a porcupine either.
We really don't have a political position
that occupies that
northeast quadrant there.
But in my opinion Evangelical Christians
are hierarchical communitarians
which obviously is not parallel
to the political groups that I am
using as my other examples.
Now these axes are
associated with differing
opinions about social issues.
Hierarchical individualists
don't worry very much
about climate change,
nanotechnology, or guns.
They are agreeing in this diagram
but they are very concerned
about gun control.
That's a red item for them.
Egalitarian communitarians worry a lot
about climate change, nanotech, and guns
but they're rather
positive about gun control.
And differences occur between
the other two diagonals as well.
And individualist egalitarian
in the lower left there
who feel strongly about involuntary
mental health treatment is gonna be
resistant to information
that promotes that practice.
Such information is gonna threaten you
if you have libertarian values
or potentially cause a rift
with other libertarians,
with your tribe.
So a lot of information is going to be
ignored or discounted if a position
placed on any of these red issues,
shall we say is presented.
Kahan and colleagues surveyed people about
how much risk they associate
with global warming
which is the green line on this diagram,
how much risk they
associate with gun ownership
which is the red line,
marijuana legalization, the blue line,
and vaccination which is the black line.
And they found very strong correlations
with political affiliation.
Liberals were very concerned
about global warming and gun ownership,
the green and the red lines,
they're high on that chart.
They weren't really fussy at all about
marijuana legalization.
And conservative strong Republicans
were precisely the opposite.
Interestingly enough
childhood vaccinations
didn't show any kind
of political division.
I think this is partly because
contrary to a lot of the panic
that we sometimes feel about
the anti-vaccination movement,
it's actually a very tiny percentage
of Americans who don't
vaccinate their kids.
Americans vaccinate their kids
at the rate of like 94, 95, 96%.
It's a very high percentage.
So maybe there just wasn't enough
variance on the data to really show up
in terms of political orientation.
So given that people hold values
related to an issue,
can you change opinions
with more information?
How does the knowledge
deficits argument stand up?
Well, the literature on this topic
provides some rather
contradictory conclusions.
And by the way don't think Dan Kahan
is the only one doing any research
on this topic 'cause he's not.
It's just that his examples
are usually pretty good
and I like his graphic.
So for a public lecture
I tend to lean more
on his examples.
But there are plenty of people
in addition to Dan doing this work.
But this study is really
one of my favorites,
and let me share it with you.
Now Kahan and his colleagues
tested this sample.
Again these are adult
Americans and their numeracy.
And he found that there was a range,
some people were really good at numbers
and some people were really,
really terrible at numbers,
low to high numeracy abilities.
They also collected information
on political leanings.
And then they gave them
a little puzzle to solve.
Subjects were asked to evaluate
a study of the efficacy of skin cream
for treating rashes.
They gave 'em a two by two table.
Some people got the
skin cream, some didn't.
In some cases the skin
cream helped with the rash,
in some cases it didn't.
So standard two by two type of thing.
And then they asked them to evaluate.
Does the skin cream work?
So it's a pretty simple,
can you understand scientific data?
And for part of the sample
the correct answer was
that the rash got worse.
For another part of the
sample, the rash got better.
So basically they kept the
numbers in the cells the same.
So the numeracy is kind of
controlled for as it were.
But in some cases the rash got better,
then some cases the rash got worse.
They basically just switched
the column headings.
And that was fine.
And then they changed it up a bit
and asked a question
about whether gun control
has a positive or a
negative effect on crime.
In other words if you
ban concealed weapons,
does this increase or decrease crime?
And again as with the hand cream example,
they jiggered the column headings
so that in some cases gun
control reduced crime,
in some cases gun control increased crime.
And in general what they found is that
most everybody stank.
Either for the rash or the crime example.
Nobody was really very good at this.
It was really only when you got into
the higher levels of
numeracy on the X axis there,
the ones farthest to the right.
Only the people who got like eight,
seven, eight, nine in
their numeracy scores,
those were the only ones
who kind of did well
on either the rash example
or the gun control example.
But then they took a little bit,
then they took a closer look so to speak
and factored in political identification.
The figure you're looking at now
is the skin cream example,
and recall that rash
increases or decreases
are both correct answers
depending on the column headings.
And here the results are separated
by party affiliation with blue
being Democrat and red being Republican.
And in general it was kind of like
the general population results.
The red and the blue
lines are pretty similar.
Nobody did terribly well.
But whether you're a
democrat or republican
you kind of do well or poorly
on the skin cream example.
But things were very different when they
asked them about gun control.
Democrats largely believed that
crime decreases when guns are restricted.
And when that's the the correct answer
they're more likely to get it right.
And when crime increases
is the right answer
they're more likely to get it wrong
because it fits with their ideology.
Similarly Republicans are more likely
to get it correct that crime increases
when you restrict guns,
and less likely to get it correct
when the right answer is crime decreases
which is ideologically less attractive.
And notice that having greater numeracy
doesn't make you more
likely to get it right
if the correct answer doesn't
fit with your ideology.
Another way of looking at
the knowledge deficit model
and ideology is to provide
incorrect information,
correct the incorrect information
and then see if people change their mind.
And there have been a
number of studies on this.
Nyhan and Riefler's is
a very good example.
Nyhan and Riefler studies all show
around about the same thing
that when people with strong opinions
are presented with articles that correct
the misinformation,
they don't always change their view.
Sometimes they double down
on their original position.
This is called the backfire effect.
And an example of this in this study
the respondents were
given a fake news article
in which President George W Bush
claimed that Iraq had
weapons of mass destruction.
Then they were given an article
that corrected that misinformation,
and then they were asked again
do you think Iraq had
weapons of mass destruction?
People who had reported themselves
as strongly conservative were even
more likely to believe that Iraq had WMDs
after reading the correction.
In another study they quoted
Pres. Bush as claiming
that tax cuts improved government revenue,
gave a correction from a Republican
economic source by the way
that no tax cuts don't improve revenue,
and then asked people whether they agreed.
Again the most strongly conservative
were the ones who double
down the backfire effect.
Now the backfire effect
doesn't always happen.
Not everybody doubles down.
Mostly it occurs among people
who are most polarized.
In another study by Nyhan and Riefler
they were looking at anti
and pro vaccination groups,
and they surveyed a group of people
and were able to divide them
into pro and anti vaccination.
They gave them an
article debunking whether
the measles, mumps, rubella vaccine
produces autism in children.
And overall by and large the autism
correction story did decrease
the number of people who believe that
MMR vaccine causes autism,
but it did not work for
that subset of parents
who describe themselves with the strongest
anti-vaccination views.
They double down.
That's where the backfire effect happened.
The investigators think
that it might have been
related to a conspiracist kind of ideology
that accompanied their
strong anti-vax views.
But the backfire effect was studied
in a series of tests on a very large
group of people like over 10,000 subjects
by Woods and Porter in 2016.
They collected information on people's
political orientation,
provided them with incorrect information,
corrected the information,
and then tested them to see
if they accepted the
correction, et cetera,
same sort of model as Nyhan and Riefler.
They found no backfire effect whatsoever.
For example they took statements
from Clinton and Obama that were not true.
Asked liberals, moderates,
and conservatives
how much they agreed with them.
Liberals are on the left of the charge,
conservatives are on the
right, that's the blue,
and the red circles there.
And take a look at that upper row.
In the first cell Obama
claimed that gender
wage gap was caused
entirely by discrimination.
Predictably, liberals agreed more
with this statement
than conservatives did,
and moderates were in the middle.
That's why the line runs as you see it,
with liberals having the higher scores.
Then when they corrected
this misinformation,
indeed the corrected line shows that
fewer people accepted that as correct.
But the shape of the line was the same.
More liberals still thought
that Obama was right.
Liberals were more resistant
to accepting the correction
than conservatives were.
And the same was true
for the other questions.
There was no backfire effect.
Similarly with the conservatives,
Sen. Rubio had claimed
that defense spending
was lower under Obama than
Bush which was not true.
Again conservatives were
more likely to believe that.
To the slant of the line
shows higher proportion
of conservatives accepting that statement.
When they corrected this statement
in general fewer people accepted it
whether liberal or conservative,
and you notice that the line is lower,
but the shape is still the same.
So there's still something going on,
but there's no real no backfire effect.
So the backfire effect is curious.
There are lots of studies like these
showing that values, ideology,
and group identification tend
to trump empirical evidence.
My personal experience
dealing with creationism
and climate change
underscores these conclusions.
Identification as a conservative Christian
and the ideology of biblical literalism
are major barriers to the
acceptance of evolution
among conservative Christians.
Similarly the values of
personal responsibility,
small government, the
importance of capitalism,
and at least recently identification
as a Republican are prime inhibitors
of the acceptance of anthropogenic
climate change for
political conservatives.
Now I wanna go into a little bit more
because a lot of times
when I talk to people
about oh I didn't see a C.
We look at both evolution
and climate change.
People say I wish those people would stop.
Well, actually it's not the same people.
So let me show you why.
First let's clear up some confusion about
political and religious conservatism.
Conservative Christians hold
certain religious views.
The inerrancy of the bible
and a personal relationship with Jesus
are the most important.
They are called Evangelicals,
fundamentalist, charismatics.
There's many other terms.
They call themselves
conservative Christians,
so that's the term that I use.
Political conservatives express
confidence in capitalism
as an economic system.
They are opposed to taxation.
They believe in minimal government,
individual and personal liberty
are elevated to a very high state.
And this is combined
with the American view
that everyone can succeed
based upon their own efforts.
The intersection of
conservative Christianity
and political conservatism is referred
to as the religious right.
Now not all religiously
conservative Christians
are political conservatives.
Social gospel Christians
are in the forefront
of many movements in worker rights
taking care of the poor and disadvantaged.
Similarly not all political conservatives
are religiously conservatives
They don't belong to denominations
that are biblically literalist,
or they just may not be
especially interested in religion.
Now this diagram is relevant to
both of the controversies
I'm talking today.
When we overlay anti-evolutionism
on this diagram,
it's clear that the religious
right is steadfastly
anti-evolutionary, yup we know that.
And most of the anti-evolutionists
are religiously conservative.
When a political conservative
is anti-evolutionist,
it's because he's simultaneously
a religious conservative.
Religious conservatism is what's
really driving anti-evolutionism,
not political conservatism.
If you know somebody is
an anti-evolutionist,
you've got a pretty good predictor
that that person is
conservative Christian.
It is a much worse, it's
much weaker prediction
that that person is politically
conservative as well.
Similarly if we overlay
anti-climate change,
climate change contrarianism,
if I say anti-climate change
that's fairly confusing 'cause we're all
anti-climate change.
But you understand that I'm talking about
people who reject the scientific consensus
on climate change, but that
takes so much longer to say.
So listen to what I mean,
not what I say, okay?
You all have children,
you know how that works.
But with climate change the main engine
is political conservatism
not religious conservatism.
As a matter of fact there's a substantial
group of green Christians
who are major, major tree huggers.
They favor creation care, religion,
theological views, stewardship theology
rather than dominion theology.
And they are outside of the
anti-climate change movement.
Similarly there has been a long
tradition of environmentalism
within mainstream Republicanism,
and not all political conservatives
are anti-climate change.
So idealogically climate
change contrarians
are politically conservative
rather than religiously
conservative per se.
If you know somebody
is anti-climate change,
that's a pretty good marker
that that person is
politically conservative.
It's a less good marker that that person
is religiously conservative.
Now there's nothing quite so satisfying
for any of us in the sciences
than discovering that there's actually
scientific validation to your prejudices.
And my colleague Josh Rosenau
was very kindly given data
from the Pew organization
and he ran some of his own analyses
looking at what other predictors
of acceptance or rejection
of human evolution,
acceptance or rejection of global warming.
Now this is a terrible looking diagram
and it just looks like a pile of spaghetti
but it's not that bad.
Let me just show you how it's actually
a pretty informative kind of thing.
Now the red lines are
negative associations,
negative correlations.
The black lines are positive associations.
And the size of the coefficient there
is a reflection of how
strong that relationship is.
The dotted lines are really
weak associations clearly,
the thicker the line the
stronger the association.
So education is a fairly strong,
is fairly strongly associated positively
with acceptance of human evolution.
In other words the more educated you are,
the more likely you are
to accept evolution.
Interestingly enough it's not associated
with global warming,
acceptance of global warming.
The more educated you are,
that doesn't mean you're more likely
to accept global warming.
The strongest negative
association with evolution
is Born Again theology.
In other words if you're a Born Again
you're less likely to accept evolution.
And church attendance is also
a very strong negative correlation.
The more you frequently attend church
the less likely you are to
accept human evolution as well.
And of course there's a
very strong correlation
between Born Again theology
and church attendance
as one would expect.
Now there's a fairly
strong negative association
between Born Again theology
and political ideology
by which in the nature of the analysis
that he was able to use,
this native, and it's
not a value judgment.
Negative refers to Republicanism.
So the Born Again theology
is associated more with
being a Republican,
that is why it's a negative.
But it's a fairly strong
correlation there.
And the strongest predictor
of anti-global warming
is political ideology.
In other words if you are a Democrat,
you're more likely to
accept global warming.
Interestingly enough global warming
and human evolution are not correlated.
So acceptance of
evolution doesn't tell you
very much about acceptance
of global warming
and vice versa which is exactly
what my impressions were.
It's so nice to have it
validated like I said.
So politics is an important predictor
of the rejection of global warming,
but not necessarily of the
rejection of evolution.
Religion is a strong predictor
of rejection of human evolution,
but it's not a strong
predictor of rejection
of global warming.
So here we are again.
Information alone, just
correcting people's
misunderstandings, just
having more knowledge
is necessary but not
sufficient to change minds.
Values, ideology, and identification
are important factors in determining
whether someone changes their mind
about a scientific issue
or really any other issue.
If changing one mind will cause a conflict
with values, ideology, or identification,
empirical factual evidence is
going to have an uphill climb.
In the case of evolution,
of anti-evolutionists,
for a conservative Christian,
they believe that the bible
is absolutely true from
Genesis to Revelations
and that you cannot pick and choose.
So if everything in Genesis is not
absolutely literally true, how
can they believe Revelations?
How can they know that there will be
a reunion with God at
the end times, et cetera,
that they'll be reunited with
their loved ones, et cetera.
If evolution is true all
that goes out the window
which is what they believe.
That is only one Christian
position obviously,
but it's one that's felt
very, very seriously.
So clearly if evolution is
right they're gonna lose big.
So you can see that there's a very strong
motivation for evolution not to be correct
no matter how much you
shovel science on top of it.
No matter how cogent your explanation
of the Cambrian Explosion,
if they're gonna use salvation
they're not likely to believe you, right?
And it's the same thing
with different examples
with global warming.
But lest, I'm just really
a very cheerful person
who talks about these
depressing things all the time.
But I don't want to leave you depressed.
People do change their minds.
Even when issues relates to these
very important issues of values,
ideology, and group identification.
Bob Inglis, former South
Carolina Republican
Congressional Representative to Congress
was very dismissive of climate change.
Like other Republicans he thought
"An Inconvenient Truth"
was just garbage and it was nothing
but a Democratic plot to seize
more central government power.
This is clearly just liberal nonsense.
In the movie "Merchants of Doubt",
which I encourage anybody to see
if they haven't seen it already
or read the book and see the movie,
he relates how he accompanied
a group of scientists and
other politicians to Antarctica
where he was blown away
by the ice core evidence
by looking at the melting glaciers,
the before and after
photographs and so forth.
It was just a stunning experience
for him to actually see the
evidence of climate change.
He also reported in interviews
that his family also pushed
him to accept climate change.
Quote.
My oldest was voting for the first time
when I ran again in 2004.
And he said, "Dad, I'll vote for you.
"But you're gonna have
to clean up your act
"on the environment."
And so I have this new constituency.
My son, my four daughters, my wife,
all feeling the same way.
By the way unfortunately Bob Inglis
was primaried in 2012 and lost his seat,
but there you go.
Michael Schermer, president
of the Skeptic society,
editor of the Skeptic magazine,
also claims a turnaround in his opinion
about climate change.
In a column he wrote
for Scientific America
he writes that he rejected global warming
'cause basically he's
got burr under a saddle
about environmentalism.
He's never liked environmentalists.
So it is just another bunch
of crazy environmentalist,
so he was rejecting that.
He writes in another essay in 2008.
Later that month I
attended a TED conference
where former Vice President Al Gore
delivered the single finest summation
of the evidence for global warming
I had ever heard based on
"An Inconvenient Truth".
Because we are primates with such visually
dominant sensory systems,
we need to see the evidence to believe it.
And the striking visuals
of countless graphs
and charts and especially the
before and after photographs
showing the disappearance of glaciers
around the world shocked me viscerally
and knocked me out of my skepticism.
Richard Cizik is the former
Vice President of Governmental Affairs
for the National
Association of Evangelicals.
He's a pro-Bush conservative
by his own words.
In an interview in 2005 he said, quote,
I had a conversion experience
on the climate issue
not unlike my conversion to Christ.
I was at a conference in Oxford
where Sir John Hutton,
an Evangelical scientist,
was presenting evidence
of shrinking ice caps.
Temperatures tracked for
millennia through ice core data,
increasing hurricane intensity,
drought patterns and so on,
I realized all at once with sudden awe
that climate change is a phenomenon
of truly biblical proportions.
All three of these
individuals changed his mind
saying that the facts,
empirical evidence in science
made them finally accept climate change.
Yet if you remember the stories
of how this change came about,
each of them experienced some emotional
concomitant of this change in view.
Inglis was under pressure from his family
to be more environmentally friendly,
plus he describes being emotionally
blown away by his Antarctica experience.
Shermer talks about
being viscerally shocked
by a presentation on climate change.
And I suspect he also
had a tribal conflict
because his science tribe
was pulling in one direction,
his libertarian tribe was
pulling him in another direction,
and he felt this conflict as well.
That's my own hypothesis.
Cizik talks about the awe he felt
in realizing the seriousness
of global warming,
and the consequences of which appealed
to his theological and ideological values.
Each of these men indeed became aware
of scientific evidence for global warming,
but each of them also had a profound
emotional experience
as part of this change.
We human beings are not
just logical and rational.
We are creatures with emotions and beliefs
that are critical in shaping us
as the human beings that we are.
What about creationists?
Do they ever change their minds?
Well, first, consider
that within Christianity
there are a lot of different
views about evolution,
from the most strict, Flat-Earthers,
through Geocentrists, to Young-Earthers,
to Old-Earthers, to
theistic evolutionists,
the farther down the creation
evolution continuum you go,
the more science is accepted.
Now of course the best kept secret
in this whole controversy
is that Catholics
and mainstream protestants
accept evolution
as the way God did it.
This is not a problem for the
vast majority of American,
of Christians internationally especially.
Now very few Christians are Flat-Earthers
or Geocentrists.
So the bulk of the anti-evolution movement
comes from Young-Earth creationists
and Old-Earth creationists.
It is among these conservative Christians
that you'll find the problems.
Liberal Christians look
at science differently.
I love this episcopal ad from the 1970s
which illustrates how liberal
Christians look at science.
To these Christians religion
is about other things
than explaining the natural world.
But even conservative Christians
are not universally against evolution.
The two best known Evangelical
institutions promoting science
are the American Scientific Affiliation
and BioLogus Foundation.
ASA has been around since the 1940s.
In order to be a member of ASA,
you have to be an Evangelical Christian,
and you also have to have a
graduate degree in science.
BioLogus Foundation was
launched more recently in 2009.
It's an online source originally founded
by Francis Collins, the head
of the National Institute of Health
and a group of his supporters.
There's a fairly large and growing
literature of Evangelical Christians
reaching out to their fellows
with the message that one can be
an Evangelical and a scientist
and also accept evolution.
Some of these are very famous scientists
like Francis Collins,
others are not known outside
of the Evangelical community.
Some of the most interesting stories
are those of Young-Earth creationists
who have converted, if
you will, to evolution.
I have read a number of these case studies
and I know a number of
these people personally,
and I have summarized some themes
from this literature which
I think are probably valid.
The process of abandoning the dichotomous
creation or evolution view
resulted in a variety of outcomes
for these scientists from,
some of them just simply
left Christianity en toto.
Others adopted a more
liberal form of Christianity,
and some maintain their
Evangelical theology
but dispensed with the
biblical literalism.
More than one of these scientists
started studying evolution
with the goal of refuting it.
This is why they went to graduate school.
They were gonna learn about evolution
so that they could fight it.
And what they found is
that the scientific data
was ultimately persuasive.
Very many of them
expressed an intellectual
disdain for their Young-Earth views.
They were affronted when they discovered
how shoddy the science of
creation science actually was,
and also the lack of self-correction
among the Young-Earth creationists,
and of course self-correction
is a hallmark of how real science is done.
For many the acceptance of evolution
was allowed, if you will,
because they started studying the bible
in a seminary or a graduate course,
and they learned that
the bible had a history.
They learned that the
bible had an evolution.
It was based on several manuscripts.
There were many authors of the bible.
The bible had a history,
and there were parts of it
that were contradictory.
And the exposure to biblical scholarship
in combination with, well,
the exposure to biblical scholarship
for many of these scientists
resulted in them being able
to look more dispassionately
at the science of evolution.
Unfortunately many
found themselves shunned
or in other ways mistreated by their
former Evangelical brethren
once they identified as having
rejected Young-Earth creationists.
But the overwhelming theme
in virtually all of
these personal journeys
was how encountering the strength
of the data and theory supporting
evolution forced them to eventually
relent and abandon
their Young-Earth views.
For these scientists the
science encountered a lot.
Yet at the same time most of the people
who have written of their conversions
to evolution recall an emotional
or ideological concomitant of the shift,
even those who attribute the change
primarily to the recognition
of the power of science.
Just to take three of the case studies
that I looked at for this talk,
Denis Lamoureux reports his shock
at discovering in his PhD studies
in evolutionary biology that
his understand of evolution
which had been derived
from Young-Earth creationist
literature was just wrong,
just totally, totally wrong.
There were transitional fossils.
There was a process and
mechanism of evolution.
Evolution was not a result of chance
and randomness and so on and so forth.
Glenn Morton was similarly shocked when
he presented evidence from,
he's a petroleum geologist,
and he presented evidence from geology
that the world had to be old.
It could not be young,
and he was totally shunned and rejected
by the Young-Earth creationists.
Emily Willoughby reports
that the painful death
from cancer her of 19-year-old brother
whom she loved dearly shook her confidence
in the truth of Christianity generally.
And the Young-Earth creationists
arguments began tomake less sense
as she studied the actual science.
Now more accounts of conversions
of this sort would be necessary
in order to test my generalizations
and see if they can be extended.
But for our purposes this afternoon,
do note that these were all,
the several cases that I
studied were all scientists
who believed that the power
of evolutionary science,
the power of geology, the
power of astronomy and physics,
the power of science changed their
orientation from anti-evolution,
Young-Earth creationism, to
an acceptance of evolution.
But remember everyone also had
some sort of an emotional or values
related experience along with it.
It's very difficult to find examples
of somebody for whom just
the science was persuasive.
There was always an emotional interaction.
Now not everybody who is
exposed to the science
has a conversion experience like this.
Kurt Wise is a well known
Young-Earth creationist.
He studied at Harvard under
Stephen Jay Gould many decades ago.
This is a guy who knows the science, okay?
Kurt will go to creationist conferences.
And when a creationist will make a comment
about the geological column
or radioisotopic dating or something,
Kurt will say, no, that's wrong.
That's not what they say.
It doesn't make him a lot of fans
among some of his fellow
Young-Earth creationist,
but this is a guy who, in my opinion,
has a lot of integrity when
it comes to the science.
So this is a guy who
knows the science, right?
But he has also been quoted as saying
that if it weren't for
his religious beliefs,
if he had only the scientific evidence,
he would've accept evolution.
So clearly, and I don't bring up Kurt Wise
'cause I wanna be depressing,
but to remind us that knowledge resistance
is a complicated subject
with much variation
in its manifestations from
individual to individual,
and even among trained scientists
who are potentially the most inclined
to respond to scientific data.
So what do we do about this?
Well the communications research people
have suggested that changing minds
require effective messages.
And of course what is
effective in one context
will be different than one
what's effective in another.
I was doing a radio show up in Canada
a couple of years ago
and the little community
where we were broadcasting from
had an anti-vaccination outbreak
and everybody was, oh my God,
people aren't vaccinating their kids.
So the interviewer was asking me about
the anti-vaccination movement,
and we were talking in general
about the importance of, you know,
science and vaccinations
work and all of this.
And she said, yes.
And it's very important
that a high percentage
of people in the community get vaccinated
so that everybody will be, or sorry.
It's very important that a high percentage
of people in the community
get vaccinated because then
the people who can't get vaccinated
like very young children or people
who have immune system problems,
they'll be protected as well.
And I just had to kind
of chuckle and say, okay,
that's gonna work in Canada maybe.
You heard immunity is gonna be
maybe persuasive in Canada,
but I'm not sure how persuasive
it is in the United States.
But there's where you have to consider,
consider the message being effective
for the audience in which
you're dealing as well.
An example of very effective messaging
that some of us will remember
was the California anti-smoking campaign
of the 1990s to the early 2000s.
Simple effective messages.
Tobacco industry lies.
Nicotine is addictive.
Second-hand smoke kills.
The percentage of Californians
who smoke plummeted
during that decade.
Ed Maibach at the George Mason Center
for Climate Change Communication
stressed that simplicity
when communicating
the importance of climate change.
Their research show that people who
believe it's happening,
it's real, it's us,
it's bad, and it's solvable
are more likely to take action.
But again what kind of message
comes out is also important.
If you're gonna take that
fourth bullet that it's bad,
well, stress is bad for humans
because that's more effective
than saying it's bad for polar bears.
We're much more concerned
about how things affect us.
Importantly the message has to come
from a trusted messenger.
And we most trust people
who are like ourselves.
People who are like ourselves speak
the same language, not literally.
They have the same values.
They share the same ideologies.
They're much more likely
to be listened to.
A friend of mine was talking about GMOs
with an anti-GMO person,
and they were just not getting anywhere.
They were just totally butting heads.
And finally his opponent said,
"You libertarians are all alike!"
And he said, "Libertarian?
"I'm a socialist."
He said the tone of the
conversation switched 180 degrees.
My friend said because I was like him,
maybe I was saying something
that should be listened to.
Evangelical Christians
who accept evolution
like Denis Lamoureux and Glenn Morton
and pretty much anybody from BioLogos
are very important messengers
to the Evangelical Christian
community about evolution.
Katharine Hayhoe is a climate scientist
who's also an Evangelical Christian.
As a fellow Evangelical and a scientist,
she's in a very unique position
to be a trusted messenger
to those Evangelicals who
do reject climate change.
The trusted messenger has
to have the right message.
And her message to her fellow Evangelicals
stresses the theology
called creation care,
and also the values expressed
in social gospel theology
which is important
to many Evangelicals.
Bob Inglis can be a trusted
messenger to Republicans,
Michael Shermer to libertarians,
Richard Cizik to Evangelicals.
Finally communications specialists tell us
that messages need to be repeated often
before they are absorbed.
I often would tell my colleagues at NCSE
that you're never gonna change
anybody's mind in one pass.
I mean my colleagues would go out,
they'd give talks at other
colleges and universities, I'd give.
We do drive by science, right?
We're there for an hour and we're gone.
The best you can hope for is that
some of the ideas that you put out
may just crack the door open a little bit
to somebody who opposes your ideas.
Maybe the next time they hear that same
series of idea, the door will be
cracked open a little wider.
So you never do it in one pass.
Effective messages from a
trusted messenger repeated often.
Repetition of course can be good or bad.
NPR released a poll in 2017
reporting the 55% of American whites
believe that whites are
discriminated against.
May I remind you that this survey data
and the actual empirical evidence
that we have does not support the idea
that minorities are getting all the jobs.
I think this is a message
that is repeated often.
No collusion.
So what does resistance tell us?
Sorry, what does research tell us
about knowledge resistance?
Well, it's partly the ideas themselves.
You can change your mind more easily
about how photosynthesis works
or that we use 10% of our brain
because those ideas don't challenge
our ideologies, values or identification
with our social groups.
We know people are reluctant
to change their minds for many reasons,
and it's not stupidity, ignorance,
or rejection of science.
It's not that people ignore
the science, they like science.
They just don't like this science.
There is evidence that
information can change minds.
It's not all the backfire effect.
And we can change our ideas
and opinions even about issues
that are very important to us.
It's just that ideology,
values, and how people
identify with others comes first
before the science can be listened to.
I would sometimes use
the analogy, metaphor,
you gotta get the fingers out of the ears
before they can even hear the science.
So if a conservative Christian believes
that they're gonna lose salvation
is evolution is true,
it's gonna be really hard
to get the fingers out of those ears.
Finally we need to consider
communication strategies
that have been shown to
work to do a better job.
Here's my low-tech suggestion.
People need to talk to one another.
We need to build up relationships of trust
which requires mutual respect.
Trusted messengers are listened to.
The most trusted are
people from the same tribe.
But even if you're from a different tribe.
You can build a trustful relationship
with someone who disagrees with you
who has different opinions.
I'm a humanist but I have built up
good relationships with Evangelical,
with many Evangelical
Christians over the years.
I think I have built a
relationship of trust
with many Evangelical Christians
because I treat them with respect,
I listen to their concerns,
they treat me with respect,
they listen to my concerns.
And we can find the areas where we agree.
And if you can find some
areas where you can agree,
then you can work out the
areas that you disagree
and then you can move those
pieces around a little bit.
If you can establish
trustful relationships,
then there's a possibility
that you can move forward.
You can get the fingers out of the ears.
And I personally believe that
if you get the fingers out of the ears,
the science has a really good chance
of being listened to because
the facts and conclusions of
science can be persuasive.
Once values, ideologies,
and group identification
aren't the most important issues
keeping the fingers in the ears.
And because these aren't
easy problems to solve,
let me direct you to the National Center
for Science Education
for further information.
Please go to ncse.com and you'll find
much more information on
the controversies over teaching evolution
and climate change,
and some ideas of what you can do to help.
And again I am just so honored
to be a Hitchcock lecturer
and thank you very much
for coming out to hear me.
(crowd applauds)
- [Man] It strikes me that
the part of the problem,
40%, maybe that they think
there's no basis for
morality without religion.
And I wonder whether in terms of ignorance
what people were ignorant about
is not so much the
general facts of evolution
but the fact that there is
an evolutionary explanation
for morality that's valid.
And that we as a species,
there's a reason for morality within
our species for the success of the species
which also has to do with
global warming by the way,
how moral you are about
your next generations.
But I wonder if much effort has been made
with the Evangelicals.
They cling to the religion, so to speak.
It seems to me because they
think they're gonna lose
their whole value system
if they don't have it.
- There are two reasons why
conservative Christians reject evolution.
One that I did talk about
is the loss of salvation.
The second one is the point you make.
They believe that good behavior,
ethical and moral behavior,
those directives come from
God, from Jesus, in the bible.
And if you don't have those directives,
then you won't be a good,
our children will grow
up to be wild people.
And this is a very serious
and sincere belief that they have.
I have found when I have spoken
to Evangelical Christians on this issue,
and I'm a humanist, I'm
not a believer in God,
and we'll talk a little bit
and I'll say, well,
there are non-theistic ethical systems,
and that comes as a real surprise
'cause they don't know that.
In this case this could
be a matter of ignorance.
And this makes them stop
because they've never really thought
that there could be other
systems of morality other than those
that were divinely bestowed.
- [Man] Scientific evidence.
- You're point I think also in continuing
was that there have been suggestions
from the evolutionary literature
for natural explanations
for the development of
ethical and moral systems.
However those explanations tell you
that we develop ethical and moral systems
as part of social behavior,
group cohesion, et cetera, et cetera.
It doesn't tell you specifically
that you should marry your cross-cousin
rather than your parallel cousin, okay?
There still is a lot of room
for philosophical and traditional
and religious explanations
for how one should behave
even if evolutionary biology can give us
some suggestions for why
these views are adaptive.
It still doesn't actually replace
the views that people consider important.
- [Man] But there is
also scientific evidence
that we're not just intrinsically selfish,
horrible animals that need
something on top of us to--
- We have to learn everything.
We need to go on to the next speaker.
Thank you for your question.
- [Man] One thing that they talk about is
trying to change the narrative.
So what would you recommend
in trying to replace someone's narrative
on evolution or whatnot?
What kind of examples would you give
to someone that they want to start
their discussion about
changing their narratives?
- You mean if you're dealing with somebody
who's an anti-evolutionist?
- Yes.
- Okay.
Well, my recommendation to, like I say,
talk to each other.
But mostly listen.
My first recommendation is if you are
dealing with somebody whose views
on scientific issue like evolution
or climate or whatever are very different
from yours and we assume that your view
is actually supported by science,
although you may have crazy views.
We'll assume that your views count.
What you need to do is find
what that person's views are
and not assume that you
understand what they are.
And then probe question, listen further,
why does this person hold
the beliefs that they do.
It may be ignorance in which case
you might direct them to a trusted source
that would give them that information.
I send a lot of people to
the American Scientific
Affiliation website
'cause these are Evangelical Christians
who will tell you why radiometric dating
is actually valid.
And if I tell them
radiometric dating is valid,
they're not gonna believe it
nearly as much as if a trusted
messenger delivers that same thing.
So I think you really have to know
where the person you're talking to,
where the person you're dealing with
is coming from and why they
hold the views they do.
I have learned some things
about anti-vaccination parents.
And these parents are
really, really scared
about something bad
happening to their kids.
And, yeah, you have to
change that narrative.
You have to assuage those concerns
but find out, listen more carefully
and find out why this
person feels this way.
It may be anecdotal.
It may be because their
cousin's brother-in-law's niece
had a child who got autism two weeks
after getting a shot.
And so that is really dramatic.
There are ways of dealing
with stuff like that.
But you need to listen a lot.
And you need to think about
what people say and
treat them respectfully.
Anyway, thank you for your question.
- [Man] Thank you for everything.
You mentioned assuaging the fears,
and you mentioned not depressing us.
Have you studied the science
of anxiety and depression?
And in particular the science
of cognitive behavior therapy
basically is the science of humans
exaggerating threats and
exaggerating their confidence.
- I believe I understand the field
that you're discussing, and
it's a very important field.
It is, however, a little bit past
the pay scale so to speak
of what NCSE does and what I have done.
I think that is a much
more clinical approach.
I think that the people,
the level upon which I am dealing this
I don't think is quite
relevant to your point.
But it is an important field.
It definitely is, so thank you.
- [Man] I have a somewhat
different perspective
on people's support for science.
Science is very reductionistic
and we have this ideology that
scientists says we understand
fundamental particles.
You understand the whole universe.
Now, of course, there
are plenty of scientists
who don't buy into this dogma.
But I think that it leads
to a sense among people,
oh well, yeah, reductionist
science is great.
I mean over the last several century,
it's given us all this great technology
and cures and all that.
But it's just covering
part of the picture.
And so that may explain part of this
that people say, oh well,
we're dealing in, say, a holistic realm
which the fundamentalists
or the reductionist scientist
just don't wanna deal with,
and which a lot of the
primary spokesmen downgrade.
I mean they tend to be looked down
on people who take a holistic view.
They look down on people
who believe in God.
And essentially they have a whole set
of dogmas of their own.
- Speaking as a biologist
I can't say that shoe
fits 'cause we deal with
a lot of integrative
phenomena, shall we say?
Thank you.
Yes.
Unfortunately we don't
have a lot more time
so maybe these will be
the last two questions.
- [Man] I'm wondering if you could comment
on the role of compulsion
in this situation.
You've talked very eloquently about
persuasion in education.
Kitzmiller I think is more than an example
of compulsion or trying to.
I'm not sure we have the freedom
to persuade in a long term
process about global warming.
It seems like the fate of Earth
and our species hangs in the balance.
- I don't know about you but I live
in the United States and it's a democracy
and I can't compel
people to agree with me.
However much better off
they would be, I must say.
But Kitzmiller, going to trial is actually
a very good example of I think your point.
Everybody remembers Kitzmiller v. Dover.
They remember the,
we at NCSE, they're some
of my NCSE colleagues
in the audience.
And they remember that year of preparation
for that six weeks of trial
and how totally exhausting
it was for all of us.
And you remember the cross examinations
and the judge's decision
and all this kind of stuff,
all of which was very complicated.
But preceding that for a year and a half,
we and the citizens in
the city of Dover worked,
we supported them, we
provided them information.
They would go every single
school board meeting
and try to persuade the school board
to not compromise the
teaching of evolution.
The policy was only the last step
in about a year and a half
of really bad decisions on
the part of the school board.
The only reason Kitzmiller
v. Dover went to trial
is because that was the only recourse.
You don't go to trial unless
you absolutely have to.
That's the last thing you wanna do.
It's exhausting, it's
devisive, and you may lose.
But sometimes you have to do it.
But if you can persuade
you're a whole lot better off.
Yes, ma'am?
- [Woman] Hi.
Thank you, Dr. Scott.
It's a pleasure to hear you.
As a fundraiser, the
last three organizations
that I have been working to build hope for
are Catholic charities, the
Center for Climate Protection,
and the Leakey Foundation.
I believe that covers religion, evolution,
and climate change.
I'm curious.
I agree with you and I wanna share
I've impacted change by
starting personal conversations
and you can start one tonight
with a relative on the phone.
It works.
And I will just ask what gives you hope,
why do you still recycle.
(laughs)
- Well, it's very,
I mean, there are two
questions that I got asked
when I was director of NCSE.
The most common question
was from creationists
which was if man evolved from monkeys,
why are there still monkeys?
They were convinced that,
oh God, I don't know.
The second most common question that I got
was from people on my side of the issue
which was how do you put
up with these people?
Why don't they just
drive you totally nuts?
And that's kind of the same
vein of your last question.
Pathological optimism.
Thank you for coming to hear me.
(crowd applauds)
(calm music)